[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مره ثانيه وثالثه ورابعه
دونالد ترامب في بؤره الاحداث ويبدو انه
سوف يظل كذلك في الحياه الامريكيه لسنوات
مقبله الاعلام الامريكي شغل امريكا
والعالم كله امس اربعه ابريل 2023
بوقائع محاكمته امام احد محاكم نيويورك
المحاكمه طرحت مجموعه من الاسئله اهمها
لماذا يحاكم ترامب اصلا نعلم الان بعد ان
فتحت المضاريف المغلقه ان ترامب يواجه 34
تهمه جنائيه دفعه واحده
وان الاربعه وتلاتين تهمه تتعلق اجمالا
بمحاولات سابقه للترامب لاسكات اشخاص
كانوا يعلمون بفضائحه الجنسيه القضيه
الاولى والاكبر والتي حظيت باهتمام
الاعلام الامريكي قبل بدء المحاكمه مرتبطه
باقامه ترامب علاقه مع ممثله افلام اباحيه
تدعى
هذا اسمه شهرتها في 2006 لكن ستور ميدان
قررت فتح هذه العلاقه ونشرها في 2016
عندما كان ترامب يخوض حملته الانتخابيه
لدخول البيت الابيض هدفها واضح التربح
المادي من نشر قصه مثيره كثير من وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه مستعده لان تدفع حتى
تتحدث السيده اليها وليس لديها ما تخسره
ببساطه لانها ممثله افلام اباحيه لكن
ترامب كان لديه ما يخسر على مستوى العائلي
وعلى المستوى السياسي على المستوى العائلي
هذه العلاقه تمت في 2006 اي بعد فتره
وجيزه من زواجه من بدء زواجه الثالث من
زوجته الحاليه وعلى المستوى السياسي اخر
ما يحتاجه اي مرشح جاد للانتخابات
الامريكيه يعني فضيحه جنسيه
تضاف الى سجل الفضائح الكثيره التي كانت
تطال ترامب على المستوى العلاقات الشخصيه
وعلى المستوى المادي او المالي
قرر اسكاته ب 130 الف دولار حتى هذه
اللحظه لا توجد جريمه في القانون الامريكي
لاقامته علاقه مع السيده ولا توجد جريمه
في اسكاتها ب 130 الف دولار لكن المشكله
ان ترامب
اعطى هذه الاموال لستور ميدانييلز عن طريق
احد محامي وهذا المحامي استرد ال 130 الف
دولار اضعافا 420 الف دولار اعطيت للمحامي
من خلال احدى الشركات التابعه لترامب
وسجلت في دفاتر هذه الشركه على انها ليج
الفيس او مصاريف قانونيه اتعاب محامي
المدعي العام لنيويورك راى في ذلك جريمه
مزدوجه الجريمه الاولى ان هذه تزوير
المحاسبي واضح يجربه القانون الامريكي
والقريب الثانيه ان هذه الاموال ال 420
الف دولار في حقيقتها ليست الا تبرع من
احدى شركات ترامب لحمله الانتخابيه
للترامب بما ان الهدف من اعطاء هذه
الاموال هو اماطه الاذى عن سمعه ترامب
واسكات السيده حتى لا تكشف قصه ربما تؤثر
على حظوظه الانتخابيه وبالتالي هذه
الاموال
كان يجب ان تكون جزءا من حملته الانتخابيه
وتخضع لنفس الضوابط التي تنظمها قانون
تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه بالاعلان عنها
اولا بالاعلان عن مصدر الاموال ثانيا ان
تخضع هذه الاموال للحد الاقصى الذي ينفق
على اي حمله انتخابيه وفقا للقانون
الامريكي ترامب لم يعلن عن مصدر الاموال
ولم تخضع هذه الاموال بطبيعه الحال للحدود
القصوى للحمله الانتخابيه
للرئيس دونالد ترامب وقتها
ترامب كرره هذه المخالفات في قضيتين
متشابهتين يحاكم
بهما الان امام محاكم نيويورك ايضا القضيه
الثانيه انه ايضا اقام علاقه مع سيده وهذه
السيده ارادت ان تفضح العلاقه فاسكتها ب
150 الف دولار وال 150 الف دولار ايضا
سجلت تحت بنود غير صحيحه في سجلات شركاته
والحاله الثالثه تتعلق باحد صغار الموظفين
لديه حارس في احد هذه الشركات بوابا
دورمان هذا الرجل كان يعلم ان ترامب متورط
في علاقه مع سيده وهذه العلاقه اسفرت عن
طفل من خارج الزواج اراد ان يفتح هذه
العلاقه اسكته ترامب باموال وهذه الاموال
ايضا سجلت في دفاتر تحت بنود غير صحيحه
مجموعه من الملاحظات الملحوظه الاولى ان
كل هذه القضايا الاربعه وتلاتين ليست
القضايا الوحيده التي تواجه ترامب الرئيس
السابق يواجه قضايا اخرى امام محاكم
مختلفه امريكيه القضيه الاولى طبعا اتهامه
بانه ضالع في التحريض على احداث سته يناير
2021 اقتحام مبنى الكونغرس امريكي القضيه
الثانيه اتهامه بالاستيلاء او الاحتفاظ
بوثائق سريه بعد خروجه من البيت الابيض
القضيه الثالثه اتهامه بمحاوله تغيير
النتائج في انتخابات جورجيا التي جرت في
الملحوظه الثانيه ان دونل ترامب كان
ومازال ينفي كل هذه التهم جمله وتفصيلا
وبيعتبرها انها تهم
وقضايا مغرضه وملفقه وسعى امس بعد خ روجه
من المحاكمه في خطابه امام انصاره لاثبات
العلاقه بين
المدعي العام لنيويورك والقاد الذي ينظر
القضيه وخصومه السياسيين يبقى السؤال هل
هذه القضايا يمكن ان تقبل تقضي على
المستقبل السياسي لدونالد ترامب الاجابه
ربما تكون نعم وربما تكون لا هذا سوف
يتوقف على قدره القاضي على اثبات هذه
الاتهامات او قدره المحامين على تبرئه
دونالد ترامب لكن المؤكد جدا ان هذه التهم
سواء ثبتت ام لم تثبت سواء يعني قرات على
مستقبل دونالد ترامب السياسي ام لا فهنا
سوف تعمق من الخلافات السياسيه الكبيره
جدا داخل المجتمع الامريكي التي تحدثنا
عنها قبل ذلك كثيرا والتي سوف نتحدث عنها
بعد ذلك ايضا كثيرا اشكركم والى لقاء